correction,
there's been a little bit of a...
overlap, the different programs of BITS,
they have their calendar slightly
different.
So.
Good evening to all of you, and...
Without any ado,
let's get started immediately.
I will quickly go through the previous
session because there was quality
attributes not covered.
I have allowed mics to...
And I will load the camera.
And initially, I will.
Start off with the previous slides.
Today,
let me tell you that I would like to take
a few minutes extra,
but those of you who have got another
class or whatever engagement you want to
leave,
please go through the recording and...
Tomorrow again, we've got a session.
We'll try to make up over there.
By tomorrow,
we would have caught up with wherever we
stand in the class.
And.
So,
it will be possible for to run the
process tomorrow.
Yeah,
you'll have to watch the recording
because...
There's something we are not in a
position to do anything about.
So one class would probably.
And as far as the quiz is concerned,
there'll be 2 quizzes running this week.
One will start by tomorrow morning,
one will start day after tomorrow morning.
So you can take both the quizzes.
I've made the slides available here.
Tomorrow's slides also,
I'll make them available today.
So,
you'll be able to go through the slides
on your own,
and the recorded lecture will of course
be available.
I'm extremely sorry that this had to
happen, but...
There's really no scope.
Oh, sorry, this is a wrong slide.
So,
when we are getting the results of first
Yeah.
two quizzes.
Oh, you're not told the results. Okay,
I'll check up with Sheela.
There must be a mechanism there so that
it becomes available to you.
Okay, yeah, thank you.
Yeah.
Yes.
Okay, I can see a few.
And since, yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, 5 minutes are not enough.
I appreciate.
But the good thing is that it is a common
time for everybody.
And if you already don't know,
you should use some of the AI tools while
answering.
Send.
Yeah, it's 5 minutes for 15 questions.
Supposed to be a little difficult,
but BITS grading is relative.
We don't have an absolute grading system.
So it's not as if, you know,
you get poor marks,
you'll get a bad grade. So if you can,
I've been a student of BITS and even with
50% marks.
It's possible to get an A-grid provided
everybody else has got below 40.
And the idea is to be able to do as well
as the others.
So if you are the only one who cannot
manage in 5 minutes,
it's going to be very serious.
So let's hope that everybody finds it
difficult to handle in 5 minutes.
The only reason you may not...
to be able to handle in 5 minutes is if
you are not using some AI tool.
So people are using AI tools and in
today's world who do use it.
Yeah, in fact,
I don't have the time just now,
but I'll share to you the relative
performance and you'll be in for a
surprise.
Just a minute.
Or tell us which AI tool can help us.
I don't know, actually, you know,
I have to find out from the students
because I do know my students use AI
tools. I'll just, since...
You're mentioning, let me, let's just,
let's take a,
I'll take a look at the scores just for
my curiosity,
because I've been seeing in the past.
The scores are extremely high and today I
just want to take a look at how people
have performed.
Is to.
TEAMS.
Okay.
Almost everybody who has attempted has
scored between 11 and 15.
And.
A 100 and.
Ten people have scored between 14 and 15.
Now what do I do? Do I get more time?
And the total number of people who have
appeared is 194. What do I do about it?
You.
Now you all tell me.
So you know exactly whom to ask which AI
tool to use.
Most of your friends here would be using
some tool.
I don't think it's possible in 5 minutes
to enter 15 questions. Obviously,
it means that you have read through the
slides and then you've intelligently used
the tools or maybe you know how to just
pick up the picture.
So, Abhishek,
I'd like you to speak up and tell me why.
See from my point of view.
You can,
you can use Gemini blog or chat that we
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah. Yeah, I suppose so.
I suppose so. See,
do in a to help you out.
I definitely know that BITS is now using
AI tools for setting question papers.
It is,
they are using AI tools to evaluate
No.
And, and to be honest,
and to be honest with all, I know very,
students' interaction. Yep.
I know very much, you know,
countable students in a group who have
attempted the quiz just only in 2 1/2
minutes, 15 questions. For them,
2 1/2 minutes, so that's yeah, so yeah.
5 minutes is even more.
Yeah. Now,
I'll tell you one thing from my
perspective. Somebody may say, sir,
when you know it is like this,
and what do you, why do you allow it?
The idea is that my experience with busy
students who are working and trying to
run a family and attend this course,
Finding 5 minutes to even think about
this course between the two classes is
difficult.
And on the pretext of doing this,
even if they're using Gemini,
they look at material relating to this
course for 5 minutes. And hopefully,
at least 50% of those people out of the
110 who have scored between 14 and 15,
have at least care to look through the
slides.
And, you know,
I have noticed since I've started doing
this in the last three semesters that
when I'm interacting with students,
they are aware of the course.
I get 2 hoops about the results.
I don't care about people are getting A's,
B's, or C's. But at the end of the course,
if the students of this course are aware
of software architecture,
They've picked up a little bit of
language.
I'm very much concerned that people
should pick up vocabulary which is
relevant to this course.
So if they picked it up,
I'm extremely happy.
So that is what we leave it at. And again,
why have I lost the slide?
The slide has gone off.
Let me open the slide again.
Children can have the dogs are leaving on
my book.
Okay.
So, we have...
Let's quickly recap what quality was.
we had the quality scenario.
And when we talked about the quality
attribute scenario,
we talked about an artifact living in an
environment, which was,
there was a response to a stimulus,
and there was a source of a stimulus,
and there was a measurement of the
response. So very, very clearly,
This entire exercise we did was about an
artifact in an environment,
getting a stimulus and responding to it.
The response had to be measured and the
source, the stimulus had a source.
This was one aspect and we said that
every quality attribute could be
Explained through a diagram like this.
We also understood that there are some...
tricks and management which can be
deployed to be able to.
Get through.
So.
This was the general scenario we
discussed.
We said that the artifact would be a
processor, a communication channel,
storage device, a processor.
The network could be anything.
The stimulus which needs a response.
which defines quality.
The response to a stimulus is what
defines quality.
How you can respond to a stimulus is the
quality of the software.
So you can have a fault, an omission,
a crash.
and incorrect timing.
some incorrect response coming, lack,
anything could be a stimulus.
And you respond to this stimulus.
by preventing it from becoming a failure.
You have to make sure that whatever
stimulus is there,
either you stop the fault from becoming a
failure, you can log the faults,
you can immediately attend to the faults,
you can intimate various actors about
what the fault was, or you can...
Make certain aspects of your application
unavailable.
You can run it on degraded port.
Any of these things could be.
handled.
So this is the way we would be able to.
A show quality, but...
Who requires this?
Why does this whole scenario take place?
Where is the source of the stimulus?
Is it from the environment?
Is it from the infrastructure?
Is it because of the developers?
Because of the users?
Because of some people who are internal
to the system, external, who puts it up?
That is to be known,
and then to be able to collect a payment
for having developed a quality software,
we have got to establish by measurement
that the response was.
Meeting up to the desired standards.
requirement of the client is being
attended to, that we mean,
that is what we meant by.
Measuring the response.
Then we went into allocation of
responsibilities.
These are the various.
management approaches available to
delivering the quality,
allocate responsibility,
have a coordination model or data model.
You have to manage resources,
mapping the architectural elements to one
another, decision on binding time,
and the choice of technology.
So, these are...
design decisions taken by an architect.
Through the scenario,
he understands the requirement,
through these design decisions and by
giving appropriate patterns.
Patterns deliver strategy.
And then you've got tactics.
So, within the framework of strategies,
you have tactics to fine-tune your
working of your software,
and when it comes,
this is the vocabulary I talked about.
Just a minute.
Yeah,
this is the tactics I'm talking about.
Now,
let's come to allocation of
responsibility.
So when we talk about allocation of
responsibility,
What are the responsibilities?
Including basic system functions,
infrastructure.
quality attributes to be attended to.
So what are we supposed to attend to?
Now,
allocate this to non-runtime or runtime
elements.
Non-runtime could be even the developers,
they can be allocated some
responsibilities.
Could be infrastructure managers,
incident managers, event managers,
anybody. They are all
people where responsibilities are located
to make sure that the quality attribute
is achieved. And runtime could be modules,
components, connectors,
various triggers acting.
So this is allocation of responsibility.
Then we have a coordination model.
When you talk about coordination model.
The elements which have to be coordinated.
or are prohibited from coordinating.
So which are the elements that will be
involved?
Then the properties of coordination,
that's timeliness, currency, completeness,
correctness, consistency.
If there's any problem with the meaning
of these words,
you could either Google it or you could
ask me.
I think these are too trivial for me to
try to cover this fairly clear.
Then what type of communication mechanism
you will have? Synchronous, asynchronous.
automated or semi-manual through logging
or through interactive action, stateful,
stateless.
guaranteed or not guaranteed,
just leave a message whether something
happens or not, we don't care.
Or it is inform and follow up.
method of delivery,
performance related properties such as
throughput and latency.
So all these things come under
coordination model,
which the architect has to give a
definite view towards.
Then we come to the data model.
So the data abstractions,
how the data will be stored,
how it will be distributed.
How it will be created.
How will you initialize the data?
How will you access it?
How will you store it?
How will you manipulate it?
translate from one to the other,
ultimately decision relating to
destruction of obsolete data because you
just can't consume, keep data infinitely.
Maybe you summarize some data and remove
details.
Then what is the metadata needed?
And I think explained the meaning of
metadata.
It's like the structure of a database in
our RDBMS or the structure of classes in
an object-oriented system.
This is all metadata. So metadata,
simply put, is data about data.
What the data contains sorts of structure
is defined by metadata.
The organization of data,
which includes whether you're going to
use an RDBMS, a non-RDBMS,
you're going to keep object stores,
text storage, XMLs.
This is all a part of data model and
Architectures get involved in these
decisions along with the respective
experts.
Then we come to management of resources.
What are resources?
Everything is a resource.
Manpower resource,
the biggest resource being manpower.
Storage resources, networking resources,
processing resources.
So how much of what resource will you
deploy to be able to
achieve what quality attribute.
So that is management of resources.
Then mapping of architectural elements,
how these elements will interact with one
another at runtime or during design time.
Where will the data be stored?
Where will you,
which elements will be assigned various
activity?
So where will you store local, remote,
distributed?
How will which module will use which
module at runtime?
How will modules combine if necessary?
Whether you'll have an orchestration
system, this is an example, so...
This all comes into mapping of data
elements.
Okay, coordination model.
PRASANJITH, just a hello from you.
Closer.
Yeah.
It's a hypothetical situation.
I'm not in a position to change
tomorrow's class,
but let's say we want to change
tomorrow's class and I want to coordinate
it. So how do I go about it?
I ask my students as to when would they
like to have the class.
And they tell me that, okay,
I get an assortment of 20 different dates
and times.
over the next one week.
Some people even suggest that the
semester should be delayed by one week.
There was an Independence Day,
why didn't we plan for it?
The other people who says, no,
Independence Day is important,
but we can have plus or minus, okay.
Sometimes there are faculty members who
are traveling, like my situation.
On that day, the faculty is not available.
If the student is not available,
we have a recording.
In fact, you know, I got a crazy solution.
They said, sir,
why don't you just record your class and
leave it?
Let it play at the right time so that the
people who are available at that time
could hear it.
PRASANJITH,
how do you like this suggestion?
Yeah.
Not feasible from our side, sir.
No,
if I had recorded the session last week,
I cancelled the class.
If I had recorded the session and left it
Yes.
for you to be able to hear at the right
time, would it be useful?
No, sir.
I also agree with you because in any case,
if it's taking place today,
it's getting recorded.
Those who want to see it recorded can
watch it, isn't it?
So that doesn't serve a purpose. Now,
Yes.
point is, ultimately,
the coordination model.
whether we have asynchronous.
Asynchronous means I conduct the class
when I like,
you hear it when you feel like.
Bits has given that option, right?
You can hear it whenever you feel like.
KEER.
But some people simply don't enjoy that.
You know, they like to be connected. Then,
like you felt like talking now,
and it became interesting.
It becomes interesting for everybody.
So we decided to be synchronous.
Synchronous means you ask the answer,
Yeah.
you speak, I speak. But at the same time,
we were a little asynchronous in the
sense that I continued with my class.
You put your question in the chat box.
When I looked at it, I responded.
OK, so this type of...
Yes, yes.
activity takes place between various
modules. Now let's take an example.
You want to,
you've got a large organization.
with about 30 different applications
running.
And all these applications are going to
send out messages.
The messages can go by SMS,
they can go by e-mail,
they can go by WhatsApp,
they can go through application alerts.
You've got applications running.
Each of the applications is capable of
giving its own alerts.
Is there any other method of pending?
Okay.
Um...
Maybe voice messages.
E, yes.
Okay, now Amazon provides a service.
I'm sure some of you all are using the
service, a messaging service,
which you can take the service and you
can just feed it the API with your
messages and they will distribute the
messages away as per the model you have
set up. Alternatively,
you can even set up...
your own infrastructure in-house to route
the messages based on priority,
based on your...
As per the quiz announcement,
at least 14 quizzes will be conducted
during the semester, one for each session.
The best date will be taken for averaging.
Yes, I missed 2 quizzes.
Any way to attend now? Okay,
thank you very much, both of you.
Parveen and Bridul,
you all have taken carried between you.
I would have explained the same thing.
In fact,
I've got emails telling me that they
missed a quiz, what to do.
You need to appear only for 8 quizzes.
And the only major thing I can do is
instead of 14, I can give you 15,
but that won't be much of a difference
because by the 15th session,
we are supposed to submit to all our EC1
evaluation. So.
More than 14 quizzes is very difficult.
Normally,
earlier I used to have 12 quizzes.
So taking 8 out of 12.
Then I realized people are very busy.
They cannot,
taking 8 quizzes out of 12 may be
difficult.
So from this semester I made it 14.
So, out of 14 quizzes appear for eight,
if you miss one, you'll miss half a mark,
because...
One mark,
I think the total assessment for quizzes
is 15 marks, and...
If you...
If you somehow appear for seven, okay,
you'll miss 1 1/2 marks. Not a big deal.
So, yeah.
Great. So this is the coordination model.
So whether you want to maintain latency,
throughput,
you want to maintain a certain
performance.
So how do you set up your infrastructure?
That mean modules,
like I was giving you another SMS thing.
You will set up a server. In the server,
you may decide that you'll have different
queues based on priority.
And priority one queue,
at any time there's material in the
priority one queue, priority two,
3 queues will be stopped,
priority one queue data will be pushed.
There again, you may have.
accounts for two,
three service providers and different
category of messages you may be sending
through different service providers.
In between, if an OTP is to go,
it is maybe on channel one. So channel 2,
three are stopped,
channel one message goes out. Again,
channel 2, three,
maybe having bulk messaging.
Channel 3 may be bulk messaging,
running on lowest priority.
So if there's something on channel 2,
which is a couple,
a burst of messages to be sent,
they'll go before channel 3.
And then again,
channel 3 will keep sending messages at
leisure.
So you've designed a system like this.
So you've taken care of the coordination.
between various levels of priorities of
SMS and how they are to be sent,
and you've created a server. Now,
how do you deposit the data on the server?
You can create an API through the server,
and from every application,
you can call that API and deposit the
data on the server.
If it's an Android system,
we have got the concept of an intent,
which is very similar.
You create an intent, pass it,
it gets into your application which will
handle your message sending. If it is...
If there are servers connected by a LAN,
you might just create a folder in the
server where you'll deposit a file.
And in the folder,
you may have a service which is scanning
the files,
picking up any new messages to be sent,
and sending them off.
You might create a database.
where you may record the messages in a
database and your message sending
application will pick up data from the
database and keep sending it.
So...
This is the choices available to an
architect.
So I'm just talking aloud because
ultimately you have to see what is the
cost, what is the throughput,
what is the desired end result.
And based on that, you make a choice.
Have I been able to address your question,
sir?
Yes, sir. Yeah, I got it. Thank you.
PRASANJITH. OK, superb. See,
in my class here, I'm just,
I'm actually here to answer your doubts
because the quantum of material available
in the slides is enormous. See,
146 slides here,
the next lot is again a big lot.
I don't even hope to cover them in class.
So
I encourage that people go through the
slides online, offline, whichever way,
and then they just catch me on any slide
and tell me that, see, this concept,
and mind you,
I'm not interested in going very deep.
Sometimes one does go deep, like say,
I try to explain to you with an example
with an SMS server or with a third party
service.
But we don't really need to go into the
nitty-gritty of how we'll do it,
but we need to understand that an
architect has to have a bird's eye view
of the options available and make choices
to deliver what has been committed to the
client. And mind you,
the client will be testing against the
agreed
test plan that this is what you intend to
deliver.
If you said that with a load of 1000
users per second,
the system must be able to respond to 99%
of the queries,
your system better deliver that.
Otherwise you don't even collect your
payment.
So.
the management of resources,
mapping of architectural, binding time.
Binding time,
I explained to you last time,
binding time is when do architectural
elements decide to shake hands.
Is the marriage made in heaven in advance
by the programmer at the compile time,
where the?
The programmer or the designer decided
this module, this use this module,
and whenever you do this activity.
These sub-modules are going to get
involved, or...
Are the marriage bid in the?
Dance club or in your social meetings,
where?
You have a requirement and you look
around who can serve my requirement. Okay,
make friends,
utilize that service at the end of it,
bye bye. So.
This is typically a case of late binding
would be where you have service inquiries,
your service delivery networks,
you have got service registries.
So in the service registry,
all the people who are capable of
providing the service,
they register themselves,
like a metrimonial, Shadi.com.
When you have a requirement, you...
Say that, yes,
I want to look up an income tax
computation under Indian income tax law.
The registry tells you, okay,
this site is available. This is the API.
You have configured it for the API.
Or there's a standard API available.
You put your query, you get your response.
Done with. Thank you very much.
Bye bye. So that is called late binding.
Late binding is also called runtime
binding,
which means at the time of requirement of
the service, you bind to the service,
take the service and forget it.
And early binding is where you plan that
these services will be integrated
together.
And choice of technology is, of course,
things can be handled different ways,
with the hard disk,
whatever storage you want.
You want solid-state or you want a
conventional hard disk,
or you'll use a tape drive.
So, these are the type of...
Requirements that.
Could be.
We talked about availability last time.
Do you understand the meaning of your
availability?
We talked about performance.
Performance is how quickly you can
respond.
The various tactics are given here for
performance.
You can either control the resource
demand or you can manage resources.
Manage resources means okay.
I'm not being able to handle the number
of websites,
the number of instances of the
application being created because of
various people opening the app.
I increase that in.
But I have a load distribution set up and
I engage multiple web servers.
Or I open multiple database database,
large number of read database and one
write database.
So readers, read me have a lag over write.
We'll get subsequently updated.
So these type of situations could be
there.
Is that checklist the performance? Sorry.
Then, usability.
Usability in the last 10 to 15 years has
emerged as the number one.
Quality attribute.
And I even mentioned last time that...
Nothing is more important.
then having a good user interface and a
good user experience.
is a very, very important. In fact,
companies are spending millions on
research on customer behavior,
user behavior,
to find out what color they like,
what shapes will appeal to them,
what would be the navigation of a site.
And there are lots of,
a couple of tips given here.
by the author as to how to handle
usability.
This is the usability general scenario.
Where we talk about end user.
Could be various types of end users,
maybe they want to,
the typical requirement is we want a
system that is user friendly and nobody
knows what user friendly is.
And whatever you may develop.
becomes a definition of not user-friendly.
So you've got to be very careful about
committing a user-friendly system.
No, the environment.
Whether we are talking about
user-friendly configuration, in fact,
configurations become so user-friendly
these days, at least,
that my level of knowledge,
I find it extremely user-friendly.
I don't know whether it's true for
everyone. If I buy a new laptop.
Configuring it has become a song, just.
Getting everything back and the
applications running in the condition
they were,
it was never as good as it is today.
To buy a new mobile,
the way everything migrates from your old
system is fantastic.
Gone are the days when you lost all your
friends just because you lost your mobile,
because you no longer had the telephone
numbers.
And you waited for them to call you up,
or somebody known calling you up before
they called the telephone numbers, so...
That is configuration time user and
runtime is of course runtime.
People open an app or they open the first
page of a website,
they look at it and says, oh,
this is not cool. And off they go.
It will be the best website in the world
having the best data,
but books are judged by the cover.
So artifact is the specific portion of
the system we are talking about.
And the responses.
The user wanted something,
the user got it or not.
And how do you measure it?
You have some standard use cases or usage,
standard user type,
a user with this type of background or
this type of education,
this type of usage, how quickly?
And happily, the user could use it.
And then you have the user survey,
where you try to find out the type of
survey report for different user category
and to deliver accordingly.
We talked about the tactics.
ADITYA.
At a very fundamental level, having,
you know, people develop sites,
they forget it.
You should be able to cancel.
Every page should have an option to
cancel.
Every page should have an opportunity to
undo. It's not like, you know,
if you pull the trigger, the guy is dead.
You got to, at least in software,
you got to make him.
Hundred.
You should be able to pause.
You should be able to resume from a
certain point.
So if I was preparing a visa application
after filling up 10 pages.
If I have to attend to a telephone call
and get back,
and then it says session timed out and I
have to start all over again, ohh,
I probably decide not to go to the
country, so...
The pause resume got to be there. Now,
for that,
a really strategies for just for the sake
of discussion,
you can save it on a local XML file,
you can have a save as option,
you can make sure that the data is saved
in the remote end itself.
But not commit, it's committed,
but it is not used as a final application.
And I have seen cases where airlines
booking agents.
They give you a call and they tell you
you were trying to book a ticket for
so-and-so place. What happened?
And you tell them, see, listen,
I had a problem with my credit card.
I'm not being able to pay through one
credit card because I don't have a limit.
My ticket is coming to 80,
000 and the balance in my card is just 50,
000 and I've got two cards.
So the person says, okay,
I'll get the payments done for you.
Then the agent helps you and splits up
the payment into two cards and you go and.
..
It's through two cards,
maybe something like that.
So then you say, oh, fantastic.
I'll always buy my tickets through this
agent. So.
You should be able to aggregate sometimes,
you know, you are doing activity,
you would like to see a summary of what's
happening. Like,
when I'm checking question papers for
bits, Milani, you know,
I'm checking 100 papers.
I would like to know how many papers I
finished checking.
And there's a request I've been to which
that say, please, at least.
Get me on the same page. Yes,
if I go backward,
I can see it on the panel that so many
papers, so many have been checked.
But it's much better if on the corner,
if I could have seen the update.
Little things that a user may appreciate
and an architect should know before the
user asks for it so that they can.
Can deliver a better and better
experience,
then when you run an application to get a
good user interface,
you maintain task models. Task models are.
..
Knowledge.
That the system has about the system.
which it uses while delivering good usage.
So you have the system model,
the way the data is being stored in the
system, user model,
the way the user sees the data visibility.
And the task model,
what are you trying to perform?
Where have we reached? Okay,
I'm making a visa application.
I have given all my personal details,
family members details. Okay,
I've uploaded my passport.
So that's the task model.
Let's keep track of my task. User model,
whether I'm an agent or I'm an actual
user,
or I'm a government agency who's
approving the passports.
So you have to create a model for each
user.
and how that user needs to see the system.
A system model is the architecture itself,
how it is configuring the system,
where it is saving it,
how the data is to be available so that
it integrates all the systems put
together. So from a user's perspective,
these things need to be studied.
So again, these are managerial decisions.
For usability.
Other quality attributes,
a whole lot of quality attributes you can
look at.
Here's a standard list of quality
attributes you can use.
But we will cover only the basic ones.
Then we have security.
Maximum number of updates that take place
regularly are security updates.
And, uh...
The various tactics for security.
And what itself is security?
Security is making sure.
That.
Data is consistent,
whatever is entered can remain there.
Unauthorized people cannot access it.
That means it should,
nobody who's not supposed to see it
should be able to see it.
The people who are authorized to see it
should be able to see it.
And.
So we normally this CIA is an important
concept.
Confidentiality,
which means people who are not supposed
to see it should not be able to see it.
Eyes integrity,
data should not get corrupted.
E is authorization,
people who have the authorized right to
see it should be able to see it.
This is a general scenario for security
and there are lots of tactics.
So what all you're supposed to be able to
do, please look at these.
If you have issues, I will.
differently answer individual questions
if there are any.
Modifiability.
Modifiability is something I'd like to
explain.
Modify British.
Particularly,
I would like you to understand the
difference between modify.
And modifiability.
This is also got a cost.
This also got a cost.
No.
Is there anybody here who has had a
situation?
In the practical life,
they've had to have system.
either the case of modify or
modifiability.
I'm sure somebody's got an experience.
Would anybody be interested in sharing it?
So, no,
so not exactly sure about the cost thing,
but certain mod modifiability we have
performed, like in one of our, you know,
cloud environments, so you know,
one of the VMs had a bad performance,
so we tried to increase the number of
sockets.
But you know, sockets and the CPUs,
but those CPUs,
then you you we end up in the REO billing,
so the cost also that point comes into
play.
Mhm.
Move.
You said that you had to think of
modifiability.
Why do you require modifiability?
Because the performance of the particular
virtual machine wasn't very good, so,
and based upon like the deliberations
with the engineering managers and and and
and one of the vendors,
we decided to do that,
but the particular application team then
ended up because...
Because of the number of codes were
higher being utilized,
so we had the cost also got increased.
Now,
would you call that modify or would you
call it modifiability?
Modify.
Modify, see?
Now,
if you have to modify a system which is
not modifiable.
Think of the enormous cost involved.
That would we would end up refactoring an
entire application then.
Yeah, yeah. Now, for many people, though,
we are all in IT and we are in software,
sometimes easier to understand when you
talk about a physical world.
Let's take Tata.
at a particular time had a variety of
cars.
On a mini truck body,
you had the Tata Sierra,
the Tata small truck was there,
you had the Tata Safari,
you had a large number of cars.
The chassis and the engine were built in
a manner so that you could modify it into
any form of a car,
right from a truck to a luxury sedan.
Great.
So that was modifiability.
It was designed for modifiability.
But when you design for modifiability,
it's a much more difficult job.
The cost of a design which is modifiable
is much more.
Now, what about modify?
I've got a car, say my.
Maruti Suzuki, and I want to...
Convert it into a.
An elongated vehicle,
what do we call that?
The name is slipping my mind,
which is from the limo, yeah, limousine.
Limo.
So you want to convert it to a limousine.
Now it was not designed to be converted
into a limousine.
Yeah, thanks. So it was not designed.
So cutting it and doing it,
it's an enormous cost. Now in software,
you have.
A Software.
which was developed.
so that you can modify it and use it in
different situations.
Say a software like SAP,
Oracle Financials. OK.
The cost of designing the software is
enormous because of the inherent
capability of modifiability and
adaptability to any requirement.
Where is?
If I develop a customized software,
the way for years and years people like
me, we've been developing.
We spent a lot of money,
developed a software for a person,
but then if you want to modify it,
that's another big assignment.
So...
Those software,
the cost one company could afford.
They paid for it,
they call the software developer for them.
But every time they want to modify it,
they have to pay a big bill.
These new softwares,
it is not affordable for one company to
design a software like that.
SAP or Echo Financials,
they have been designed for a large
number of people to use.
But then?
To modify them and fit them into a
particular usage doesn't cost as much.
So lots of people have got into the
business of just customizing the
softwares for a specific requirement.
So the cost of modifiability and modify
is very important to understand the
difference.
And what we need to understand is that
modifiable software,
if somebody is asking for modifiability
as a quality attribute in the software,
charge him the earth.
Let him realize that modifiable software
doesn't come cheap.
And that person better be planning to
run the software which can be used in
different situation,
things like Shopify maybe.
But if you want to cut costs,
you design a software which is not
modifiable,
be ready to pay a big bill when you want
to modify it.
Have I been able to come across to you?
I think the Russell,
who was I speaking to?
Yes, sir. Say it was me, Renwick.
Yeah, yeah. So, right, okay. How do you,
what do you think of it?
Have I been able to bring out the
difference?
It's important for me to bring out the
difference between the two to you.
Between modifiability and modify.
Have I been able to do it?
Ohh.
To a certain extent, yes sir.
Yes, what?
Okay, no, let me still try that.
If you develop something.
which can be easily changed.
I've got to parameterize all the entry
points.
I've got to have the design which is
moldable very easily.
I call that modifiable.
I'll have to do a lot of planning in
designing it initially.
Then when I need to modify it,
I'll be able to do it in a short time.
Maybe just change the parameters and
it'll change. Correct?
Correct, sir.
But if I do not design for modifiability,
it'll the initial cost will be lower,
but when I need to modify it.
There could be major structural changes
also, architectural changes,
which are going to cost a lot of money.
So modifiable software costs more to
But...
construct, less to modify,
and that is why you make it modifiable.
ANAND.
Yeah.
Software that costs a lot to modify,
you may have saved cost by not making it
modifiable.
Right.
Go to, sir.
Okay.
Very good. APARNA has put it very clearly.
Modifiability is a plant thing to
accommodate things in the future.
That is modify is post delivery,
which you attend,
you cross the river when you reach it.
And APARNA,
you'll agree with me that both are good
things.
It's not as if one is good and the other
is bad.
If...
Yes.
Everybody, yeah.
So it depends on the situation and you as
the architect have got to take the
decision.
Guru RAJ says that an RDBM is not easy to
add columns, yeah, but in non-relational,
it's easy.
And that is why when we design database,
we try to create views for the developers.
So let the developers work on views,
let them not use my tables directly.
So it requires a lot of effort to
generate the correct views so that
developers can work with views.
So that creating views and delivering
them to developers itself.
Mix and RDBM is more modifiable.
Whereas you seem to be into RDBMS.
Hi, sir, not really. Just as a developer,
we tend to use work with databases for
OKOK.
input data and output data.
Right, right, right, right, so that is it,
and even RDBMS is, you know,
if you develop an RDBMS for modifiability,
it requires much better design,
and some of the...
Best database RDBMS database structural
designs are very simple to look at;
they don't even need to be modified,
and you know, if you go into it,
if you create designing RDBMS for say for
these for applications which are going to.
..
shared applications.
And you have, uh,
just thinking of a relevant example.
You have applications which...
Are going to be used by multiple.
users,
you have to design the structure in such
a way that you can add attributes.
Maybe a level of normalization,
but you'll have to pay a penalty on
performance if you try to do it.
So it depends on the volumes.
If you have very large volumes,
you'll go for in an... GURURAJ,
you use the word non-relational.
Do you mean no SQL or you mean purely
non-relational?
Yes, yes, no, no sequel.
Yeah, so when we say no SQL, we have,
you know,
less other people misunderstand us
because there are lots of people in this
place who may not be familiar with
database. No SQL means not only.
SQL. Okay, so normally these database,
they have SQL also,
and they have object stores and text
stores, document stores.
They can handle multiple types of stores
in the same database module.
So I think let's take a 10 minutes break,
we'll get back.
And those of you who have to part at the
regular parting time do part,
but I will continue for some extra time,
okay?
So,
let's take a 10 minutes break and be back,
yeah.
Yeah, hello.
Now, we talk about interoperability.
In today's world.
To Pub.
Asha Ravin.
Next example.
Okay.
So, let's talk about interoperability.
A lovely example of interoperability is
the way apps in Android.
interplay with one another. In fact,
Android has been designed for
interoperability.
You.
Apps in the Android environment interact
with each other as if they belong to one
single app.
Everybody can talk to everybody.
Apps can use one another.
They can pass messages to one another
through a standard.
framework provided by Android.
So that's a great thing.
Today, more than ever before,
interoperability has become a hallmark
for any good software.
Say you had an ERP solution.
Which could not access certain.
database platforms.
That itself becomes a disqualification.
So today you have...
Oh.
Save.
Financial application.
You should not be bound to a given
database. In fact,
Windows itself.
They provide you open database
connectivity, which allows you to connect.
through the ODBC socket to any database
at the back end.
So...
Large variety of database connectivity.
Now, when it comes to applications.
Open standards have been developed.
When you talk about open standards,
we mean that these are standards.
We don't belong to a single company.
Anybody who wants to develop an
application follows them. Initially.
Everybody had their own standards.
If you get into the Apple ecosystem,
you have to stick to Apple.
You have to have an Apple,
you have to have Mac,
you have to have an Apple TV.
So much so,
they wanted to have their own maps.
Eventually they would like to have their
own mailing service,
but gradually there's a realization that
you've got to concentrate on your core
competencies.
Accept connection with other ones.
and allow other worlds to connect with
you.
So, this...
Type of a setup.
is interoperability.
So 2 separate systems,
maybe by the same manufacturer,
maybe by different,
maybe belonging to a totally different
world,
having different communication protocols
for all you care.
The ability to exchange meaningful
information and work together.
So.
It's not yes or no,
it's a degree of interoperability,
the shades of meaning.
And when you get into a discussion with a
client,
you've got to get into exact nitty
gritties about what you mean by.
interoperability. So source is a system.
It's another system which wants to
interact with you.
So that system requires information from
you.
baby data stored within you.
or your location information.
There are two systems,
the system that we want to interact,
the system with which it wants to
interact. So this is the artifact.
And environment could be the system is
lying idle.
It has got to be connected up or it could
be runtime.
Now, when it tries to interact.
The response could be.
It simply rejects.
If it doesn't meet a certain
specification set,
there might be specifications it should
be able to request.
Or if it is appropriate,
it should be able to accept the message,
perform whatever is to be performed,
and return the values.
And sometimes there will be more than one
systems involved.
There could be an orchestration involved.
ANAND.
The measure of interoperability would be.
How many requests could be attended to?
And if they attended to,
whether they attended to correctly or not,
if things go wrong when they interact,
that's also not a good thing.
So,
here is an example given: a vehicle
information system sends.
a current location to the traffic
monitoring system.
The traffic monitoring system combines
our location with other information.
Overlay the information on Google Maps
and broadcast it.
A location information is correctly
included, the probability of 99.9% now.
Let's talk about a sophisticated scenario
here.
And let's take up an example of vehicular.
close.
You have vehicular lands which are
becoming popular on major highways in the
developed countries.
I'm told even in India.
Anybody here who's working on vehicular
lands?
So,
I was hoping to find somebody actually
working on vehicle then.
I can briefly tell you what it is about.
What is happening is that...
Vehicle,
when they are moving on a highway,
they may not have very good.
Access to.
DUTTA.
or to the internet.
And the vehicle itself.
You may not like to subscribe to an
internet connection for the vehicle.
But a vehicle.
Can be logged on.
To a pillar to pillar length.
It's a local land which does not have any
data from outside.
It's not as if you can browse the
internet on it or access a database or an
EPA, but...
Through post-to-post connection,
it can connect.
To the highway system,
now the highway system allows all cars
moving on the highway to connect to it.
And...
shares information about traffic
congestion through an AI module,
which monitors the traffic densities and
shares the information of the vehicle.
Now,
future vehicle would be designed to
utilize this information to synchronize
with other vehicle on the route.
So, you have a large number of vehicles,
say, moving from...
Delhi to Ahmedabad.
And there's a crossroad in between,
which has some major...
Traffic between Maharashtra and Gujarat.
Now, both these routes,
if they are vehicular land.
Cars moving in a given direction if their
vehicle systems.
have the configuration,
they can lock into a cloud and gradually
synchronize their speeds so that a large
number of cars start moving together in a
single bundle.
And you can have meaningful bundles
depending on what is considered a
reasonable cluster, maybe 20 cars,
40 cars.
Form a cluster,
and this cluster moves together,
and if there is any breaking,
this whole cluster will break.
They will maintain the uniform distance
according to the model of the car,
and the...
type of breaking system they've got.
So automatically the cars will maintain
the distance between themselves and they
will move in that direction.
If there's a crossroad,
the speed of the two clouds will be
synchronized in such a way that when one
cloud reaches the crossing,
the other cloud does not reach at the
same time.
So cars will cross a busy,
2 busy highways will cross each other
without a single breaking.
There's no need of green and red light.
Because when one cloud is moving,
the other cloud is not.
And cars which do not synchronize into a
cloud.
you'll have to make some exception
arrangement for them.
So this is the type of interoperability
we are looking for in the future that all
cars, their systems,
the navigation system will be expected to
interoperate.
And already there are international
standards being set up for such
communication protocols.
And I'm told there are some highways
because
In one of my previous batches,
we had two people,
two students who were actually working on
the system in India.
The objective interoperability is that
systems should be able to work together,
utilize each other's benefits,
utilize information from one another,
and work as a unified whole.
So there's a request for exchange of
information.
There's interoperability and the request
is handled correctly.
No.
For interoperability.
One is approach to locate.
Locate means discovery services.
The discovery service which tells you
what services are available and.
What is the availability of the service,
what it can do,
and you connect through the discovery
service,
you get to the service and utilize it.
The other is manage interface.
Manage interfaces,
one is tailoring an interface.
You have standard services available.
They have their own interface which is
declared.
Your system probably doesn't have the
same interface as theirs.
You tailor an interface so that...
create an adapter maybe to connect to the
interface. Other is orchestration.
Orchestration means a whole bookie of
services.
which are controlled by an orchestration
system which knows those services.
You require the entire range of services,
but as a mixture,
you require some networking service,
you require some storage,
you require some processing service.
So all these services will be utilized
together.
To be able to.
Yeah.
Don't.
So,
this is a way interoperability could be
handled.
Locate a service through a search.
On a loan directory service.
Multiple levels of indirections might
take place to be able to get to the
service.
So, indirection is a very, very important.
approach in software development.
One of my friends who is Hindi speaking
told me,
so you don't have to understand Hindi.
All he meant was that if you can't access
a service trait, well,
we'll get it through somebody else.
In fact,
The international economy has learnt it
very well, you know,
if you can't import from China.
Then you import from France,
the designer in France,
manufactured in France, but everything,
the material has all come from China. So.
People are very happy importing from
France and Italy,
where the basic material has come from
China. That's okay, indirection.
Very similar to what we'll end up doing
when we take a service from a third party.
So...
Orchestration is a control mechanism that
coordinates, manages,
and sequences the invocation of services.
So with service when,
how much of it coordinate between various
services?
A very good example of orchestration
services Kubernetes.
We'd love to take a brief look at it
later on in the course,
but many of you would be already
utilizing it because if you're doing any
serious work on the cloud and using
Dockers,
chances are you're familiar with these
services.
If those of you are not familiar.
Just make yourself a little familiar
about it,
because when you're doing a course in
architecture,
peripheral knowledge on this type of
thing will help you to appreciate what is
being talked about.
Then.
Tailoring interfaces, services available,
but the interface is not exactly what you
wanted.
Maybe the speed of movement of data is
not compatible to the speed you are
handling.
So you might have to handle some sort of
a cache, a buffer.
Maybe.
There's jitter in the data,
you need to smoothen it out.
Maybe you need to translate.
It could be language transaction or
digital transform.
Analog to digital, whatever it could be,
so.
You can have managed interfaces to handle
the data transfer.
So, checklist for interoperability.
First is allocation.
Firstly,
you got to understand the systems that
need to interoperate with one another.
Ensure that you understand the
responsibility of each system,
why you are interacting, what you'll do,
what the other system will do.
Whenever you are collaborating with a
third party,
you need to have a very clear
understanding of the terms.
And sharing of responsibility, you.
have to have a protocol for acceptance of
requests, exchange of information.
Uhh.
No, no, then it's local traffic.
Yeah.
So, Kaushik, if it is persistent,
know what you are typing.
Play.
OK, so.
Whether you have to accept the request?
whether you need to confirm or not.
If it is very important that there has to
be a connection,
then you have a concept of acceptance.
if the data does not match,
there should be a
Call back saying that it doesn't match.
If there should be a log maintain for.
Either for all activity or at least for
the thing.
the requests which could not be met.
Maybe if it is a repetitive.
problem,
it needs to be escalated automatically.
so that people who are handling the
activity logs or event logs can take care
of it automatically.
Procedures could be there.
Then there could be.
Test for whether it's a trusted request
or not, because when you are.
Allowing interoperability,
you have to confirm trust level.
Actually, let's put it this way: ABASS.
We are talking more about solution,
but the level at which we are speaking,
we are not going into detail, so...
To an extent, the enterprise.
Aspect comes in.
So we talk about it as software
architecture.
So I emphasis on the software side.
And we're talking about software
solutions.
But the moment you talk about an
enterprise architecture.
The reality is you cannot really cut
these into pockets.
In a corporate,
you may be called a solution architect or
an enterprise architect.
Your company would have divided the rules
and...
The definition of these rules is as...
Defined in your company.
So, we will not.
Really look at it that way, but...
I would say that our course here is
focusing more towards a solution
architects role,
if you look at it that way.
But we definitely need to.
understand it from a combined perspective.
It's this course is really a little at an
abstraction level; it is,
we are not really.
Ohh, it's sort of...
Maybe after doing a MTech,
if you want to do a,
you really can't do a course in
architecture,
you probably have to take up research on
architecture of a particular type. So.
If which means you will either go and try
to study the architecture of Amazon or
Azure or Google and then try to study as
to how that can be improved.
Maybe you'll have to join one of those
companies to do it.
At that level.
But yeah,
we are at the software ARCHITA level,
which means basically for the normal
corporates who are handling a good size
IT infrastructure.
But this is not a course on
infrastructure management, definitely.
Actually, in today's world.
Infrastructure management.
has got a lot of management and the
technologies are handled by specialists.
So you get attached to various
technologies,
but the moment you're setting up a
solution,
you're taking an abstraction from all
these people, you're using,
utilizing their services.
And the moment we get into a little bit
of the management side of architecture,
now when we start studying the economics,
because in this course we'll be talking
about the economics of architecture also.
and how economics and management factors
influence architectural decision.
And they influence not in a small way.
They impact in a very big way.
You cannot take architectural decisions
in isolation of business
And commercial considerations.
You get what you're willing to pay for,
and what you're willing to pay for is
totally different from company to company,
and...
When you say what you pay for is not just
whether you're willing to pay for quality
or not. Quality in which dimension?
But you're looking for interoperability,
modifiability, availability, performance,
usability.
stability, security.
And how much money you're willing to
interested in putting into one,
knowing fully well that if you put more
money in one,
you have to put in less than the other.
So as a technical person,
you will belong to one of these areas.
And when you belong to one of these areas,
you will want the best.
And as far as you are concerned,
the client should pour in as much money
as the client can in that area.
But then...
The architect cannot take that type of
view.
The architect has to do a balancing act.
So that's what we look at a little later.
Mapping.
No, ABASS,
we are not going to look at how to draw
data flow diagrams in this course.
We are not looking at high level low
level diagrams.
That would all be a part of a course in
software engineering.
So, as I told you, that is at a slightly..
.
Lower level of abstraction.
where we'll be understanding the software
in more detail.
But here we are getting into a level
above that, a higher level of abstraction.
As we said, architecture.
After architecture comes software design,
then we have component design.
Then we've got user interface design.
So when we talk about data flow diagrams,
we are talking about software design.
And software design is not just data flow.
Data flow is that data aspect of software
design.
There are lots of things we learn when we
talk about software design.
We are talking about the...
static and dynamic aspect of a given
application where we talk where we talk
about class diagrams, sequence diagrams,
collaboration diagrams,
we talk about state diagrams,
but that is not a part of this course yet.
My request is that you make yourself
familiar with those if you have not done
it as a part of any other course at a
more basic level. Okay.
So.
For interoperability,
the critical mapping is that of
components to processes.
So when we talk about interoperability,
what are the components,
what are the processes,
how will the communication take place
with the processor,
communication with the...
With different.
Opents.
Resource management.
Now,
when you are talking about
interoperability.
There's an interaction between systems.
And when you're interacting between
systems, you may not know in advance,
particularly when you're going in for
late binding,
as to how much request is going to be
there.
Officially, a class gets over at 5.40.
So I will say bye to the people who have
to leave because of other engagements
because it's over.
But I'm going to continue for another 15
minutes.
Two.
do some justice to what we are supposed
to cover. And those who have to leave,
please bear with us and view the
recording.
All I'll say is that I look forward to
meeting you again tomorrow.
I don't remember the exact time it says
it's announced in.
Beams.
I can take a quick look.
I think for 7 to 9 P.m. OK, so tomorrow.
7 to 9pm.
Whatever time you can join,
you're most welcome.
We'll continue over there.
But I'll put up the slides today itself
so that people who are not going to be
able to sit through the session can just
page through the slides and drop in for a
while if they feel like.
Thank you,
I'm just continuing with the class.
So binding time, I told you about it,
whether it's early binding or late
binding. With late binding,
there's a lot of issue regarding planning,
volume planning.
Yet based on past experience and based on
the type of loads that exist,
you are able to work out binding time.
But if you cannot,
then resource planning can be difficult.
Sometimes
When these resources are available on an
open network, the capacities are limited.
So when there are too many requests,
it simply bounces the request.
Now that can be a bit of a problem if you
don't have prearranged agreements.
But most of the services that are
provided on public platforms have an
ability to take robust.
requests.
A typical example would be location
services offered by Google.
The very large number of people, in fact,
some people now have shifted.
Amazon is now using...
In Amazon in India is using a map system
provided in India. What is the name?
Map something.
Many of you might be already using it.
Maps, I think it's called Mapples, M.A.P.
P.L.S.
Mapples, I don't know any.
Users of MPPLS Map Plus.
I heard of it, sir,
like it is a product by Map My India
Yeah.
Company.
Right. Now, my usage, it's a recent usage.
I recently noticed that,
was it Zomato or was it Amazon, somebody,
one of them has started using it also.
And my exposure was that it was a bit
slow to respond compared to Google Maps,
but that may be just a one-off case.
But it seems to be more up to date.
It has got...
The mapping seems to be in fairly good
detail.
So whatever it is.
So now a service like that,
they should be able to deliver the
volumes.
Like initially we had problem with the
IRCTC. In a previous class,
somebody pointed out that in the early
days,
IRCTC response used to be a big problem.
Acha, Comms Integration, Mahindra. DILRAJ,
could you share some information with us?
Yeah, please go ahead. You can unmute.
I have allowed everybody to unmute.
You can unmute and speak.
So, I think he is a is trying to say,
you know, Mahindra Kash, you know,
Yeah.
Right.
where we have that thing on display in
the front of the dashboard.
Okay.
Right.
So, usually for other clubs,
it comes with by default of Google names.
Today, we have the new cars,
the Android Studio is already set up,
Okay.
Google Maps is already integrated,
maybe in...
Google Map on Mapples.
No, no, Google Map is, I mean,
I have seen the 90% of the cars,
they use the Google Maps.
He is talking about the Malindra vehicles,
which I'm not aware,
maybe they have the integration with this
Okay, okay.
Here you have got Amritesh is telling us
Amazon Maps in the vehicles, because...
that Suzuki vehicle 2 two-wheelers.
Turn by turn navigate system by Mipples.
Ohh.
Okay,
so maples is becoming popular in India
for whatever reason.
Maybe the government push.
So, just, just...
Just asking,
is it somehow better than Google Maps?
Yeah.
I mean, just trying to get a feedback and.
..
I told you,
comparing at this stage will not really
be fair,
because Google comes with an enormous
background and exposure.
But maybe the Indian government is,
the Indian government is trying to
encourage an Indian product
Yeah, yeah, at.
And, well, why shouldn't they? After all,
we have...
So,
the traffic info actually is pretty much
good, at least in Bangalore,
where the Bangalore traffic BTP is
Yeah.
Okay.
working with only,
so it's quite updated with recent
Okay.
closures and other things.
Right, right.
And they'll definitely catch up because,
you know, India,
if you talk about the IT market or any
social media,
if you look up the user base in Facebook
or WhatsApp,
India constitutes a significant
percentage.
So when a country like China can take an
approach that, you know,
they like to use their own apps in their
country,
and that's making China a strong economy.
You don't,
after a lot of foreign chain pulls out
when you,
every utilization of Google Maps,
you are paying to an American company.
So naturally,
it's a great way to save the country
foreign exchange.
So we can have a good product.
And no reason why we can't have a good
product at least for India,
because India has got its own satellites
now. So.
whatever it is.
But what they have to really worry about
is the interoperability and being able to
handle the load.
So,
that's going to be a very important thing,
and since this is this is a late binding
issue,
because you just don't know when you're
going to get how many hits.
Suddenly there's a huge traffic condition
and there's a big requirement.
Everybody starts sitting. Now here,
to handle better type of responses,
getting better performance with good
interoperability, with performance.
What may have to be done is that...
You may have classes of requests.
So if you are,
when a particular commercial organization
is using it for the movement of their
people,
like say Zamato is using or Amazon is
using,
then they may be given a higher priority.
It'll be a simple hit which will give
them a response.
Then, the way it is designed.
If you have to download the map from
Google every time.
then it slows down that time taken for
the map to download.
But if you are designing a system for
navigation only within India and within a
city,
the system may have been designed to
download the map in advance.
So all you have to download is a location.
or just an update of the map.
So some architectural changes can make it
perform much better.
And location services,
if the Indian satellites provide good
location services, after all,
the number of things will be less.
Even companies like Google and Facebook,
they are now trying to have local
storages. Even a company like, say,
Netflix,
they've got this content delivery
networks,
which are setting up their servers as
close to the actual users as possible.
to try to deliver better performance.
So interoperability, performance,
availability, all these things,
they combine hand in hand and they try to
deliver the best they can.
So choice of technology is what you will
use in the interface boundary.
Then we come to testability. Testability,
again, very similar to modifiability.
What is testing?
And what is testability?
Testing has got a certain cost.
There's an approach to testing.
You can always have the system.
Installed it on.
Test lab on a testing rack and test it.
Testability would be how easy it is to
test,
and which would include being able to
test while it is running live.
Testability would be involved with
logging.
What details of logging you maintain,
whether you can switch in and switch off
detail logs,
whether you can run trial data parallelly
with in production so that you can test
the working of the system.
Testability also may be of various types.
It will be functional testing,
it will be performance testing.
And nowadays, people call it NFR testing.
Non-functional requirements,
which means all these NFRs that we are
studying, quality attributes, testing.
For the satisfaction of the NFRs to the
standards required by a client is also
testability.
So running these tests in a live
environment is...
a game that costs a lot.
You have to invest in making software
which is testable.
A very popular logging system is called
Log4j.
I don't know how many of you are using it,
but this is an open sourced logging
platform.
Once upon a time it went into a lot of
trouble, created problems. Yeah,
it looks like there are people going to
it.
So let's look at,
I'm not stopping any individual pieces,
there are too many.
You know,
tester completes a code test during
development and performs a test sequence
whose results are captured.
That gives 85% path coverage.
This is the concept of path coverage in
testing within three hours of testing. So.
This is the type of testability.
Testability means easier testing.
whenever increment takes place.
So whenever the increment takes places,
we have automated tests,
we may have an automated regression test.
With every small change,
if you can run the regression test and it
is automated,
it becomes very easy to deliver small
increments of software at regular
intervals.
So.
The architect may design it in such a way
that it reduces the high cost of testing.
benefits,
particularly achieved through automated
tests.
There are two categories of tests:
controllability and observability,
and the second one is...
limited complexity.
The system should not become complex for
testability.
And controllability is whatever data you
give,
you should be able to control what data
you are giving.
You should be able to observe the result.
Mostly through locks.
Here you are.
controller observation of system state
and limit the complexity.
Structural complexity, non-determinism.
And when it comes to controller
observation, spatial interface,
record replay, localized state storage,
keep the state where state changes may be
recorded.
abstract data source, sandboxing,
that means you.
Take the software,
isolate it from production,
and be able to test it.
So you should be able to handle that.
Executable assertions.
This is something which those of you are
programmers would be.
aware of assertions, very often,
say in Java,
you have assertions which are
pre-assertions,
post-assertions for every function.
The ones which run when the program is
running, no changes are allowed, so these.
They check up with the.
When the variables enter a particular
function,
will they maintaining the input
requirement or not?
We call them previous sessions,
like the value should only be positive of
a given integer, or...
The salary range should be between 10,
000 and 1 lakh.
So the system has not tested for beyond
that. Pre-assertion,
make sure that if your data is not within
that range,
it will immediately respond by saying,
sorry, data is out of range.
Post-assertion is calculated result
should not be outside a given range.
Because some system has to work on that,
so if it goes out of the range,
the other system may not work properly,
and...
The other one.
In.
Villiant.
Sometimes, you know.
This is not really a concern of an
architect, but...
The person will be writing the test.
That person would require to have
programming knowledge, and...
Sometimes if the certain values go beyond
an acceptable limit,
even within a function,
though the pre and post may match in
between.
Let's say the area size goes beyond a
certain value.
or values exceed the space provided in
storage.
So when you're running a loop,
you might test for invariants.
That means that even when during the
running of a program,
value should not go outside a certain
range,
or say a value should not go negative.
Any test like that,
and these are instructions which are
available in Java for checking.
Ashutosh, they are not Anant, Ashutosh,
and they are not mock tests,
they are real tests.
You actually put them in the software,
and when the software is running,
you can log that it has failed the pre or
poster session, or...
You can even throw up an exception based
on that.
And definitely,
if it is happening in the live run,
it goes, the values go out of range.
You would like to maintain a log.
Very often,
we don't want programs to stop during run,
depending on the criticality of the error.
So there again, you can set conditions.
If it goes beyond critical conditions,
you simply will raise an alert and you
will not execute the.
application.
Maybe just return an error saying that
sorry,
this service cannot be offered at this
time. Please check back later.
Sometimes you put an insert comment like
that.
Actually, there is a malfunction.
There's an invariant which has thrown up
an error, but you don't want to.
Yeah.
get the user hysterical,
you maintain a log and immediately get
the log attended to.
And if you have a proper log with on this
pre and post in this thing, sessions,
you are in a position to attend to them
very properly.
So this would be testability.
Limit complexity,
and these are the management issues
involved.
So with that,
we will close today's session.
Thank you very much for bearing with me.
Everybody stayed on for the extra time.
And any difficulties you have in
understanding any of the tactics,
particularly, you know,
we have got so many named tactics that
are taken up.
Please bring it up in the beginning of
the next session.
I will attend to the tactics.
That's even tomorrow's session you can
bring it up, or the session thereafter,
because many of you may not be able to
attend tomorrow's session.
Do bring it up in the session next
Saturday.
So long, bye-bye, take care,
enjoy the weekend.
Thank you, sir. Happy weekend.
Thank you. Thank you, Pratik. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you, sir. Happy weekend.
Thank you. Thank you.
Sir.
Thank you, sir.